thank you Yasser we are here with Rue
Yang Yang after her first Victory here
at her first U.S Chess Championship
rouyang welcome to the show
congratulations how do you feel right
now after your first Victory I feel
pretty good um it's like first win this
tournament so it's always a good sign
let's take a look at the game because it
definitely felt like it was quite a
dominant display by you yeah yeah except
like the opening part
did she surprise you at any point
I was expecting her to go like Ace like
takes takes an A6 or like Knight C6
um
yeah but she decided with this new idea
Knight F6 Knight C3 and D6 for her is
this a new idea
um
um usually I think people go like Knight
C6
there's like a whole other like system I
guess and then um D6 uh D6 I've like
never like seen this before but I guess
it kind of went into some neither
position
um except after like fish would be it's
like neither but they should be there in
the black plays E6 yeah
um I wasn't I usually don't play this
side so A6 F3 well this basically
transposed into some sort of I think
there's like some G4 idea somewhere yeah
it's a chef in England yeah right yeah
B5 uh if
A4 okay very interesting yeah I thought
for a long time here because I was
worried about some um A4 and like black
has some like D5 ideas except like B4
she did that in the game but I think
after Knight A2
um and then instead of D5 she could I
think I was calculating like her playing
E5 first but it might not be that good
E5 that'd be three and then D5 yes
maybe I don't know I wasn't sure about
this I mean I it says like White's
better but I I wasn't sure it's not that
clear yeah right
um but she decided against that she
decided to start immediately with D5 and
then E5 Knight D7 F4 and you managed to
change the structure yeah were you happy
with this change yeah
um this is like kind of like a French
like structure
um and
and I've like her pawns on B4 upon B4 is
kind of like weak and if you have a
place A5 I could the B5 squares week so
it's there's like it's kind of hard to
do something about that pawn
um Bishop D3 Bishop D3 Knight takes you
decide to take with a c Pawn open up the
C file it also controls the C4 and E4
Square that's very nice yeah yeah that's
a good point
um Bishop to C5 I think it's a bishop B7
um I was calculating Bishop E3
um D4 yeah I saw Queen I think I saw a
queen G4 and then takes takes Rook d8
Knight B3
um that that I save upon that is correct
if you take on B3 Knight to C5 this is
just simply yeah losing very nice fine
by you and she decided against that
probably because I think she also saw
that
I think I was just better here
um I think and I suffered like I feel
like I play kind of like unprecisely uh
like I like maybe like Bishop like
Bishop D4 Queen F2 I mean I think it was
fine but I feel like I she got some
things okay
yes Queen 37
but still you you have this strategical
grip long term strategical grip it seems
like
it wasn't that good I I mean I'm like up
a pond but she has to do something
because finally she gets the bishop yeah
she can't like she can't allow me to
play D4 because yeah then you get
everything you you want in the position
and she did allow you to play the move
d4 and now now this is good
Ryan congratulations
um how did you prepare for this event
this is your first U.S women's
championships you're going to be facing
so many champions of the past and
potentially of the present how did you
prepare
um I mean I I like really prepared too
much I just went through my openings and
just tactics and things
um yeah
we hear a lot of uh you know the
Jennifer use of the competition saying
that they have to balance the academic
career with trust you have to do that as
well you're in high school right now
yeah and how does that work yeah I'm
missing a lot of school so I have to do
like do like do like the homework and
essays like during the tournament so the
professors will not allow you to take
them later on in in the Academic Year no
probably not
guys they don't cut you any slack uh
you know you you've got an excuse not
every student has this has an excuse
that you have sorry teacher I couldn't
do my homework I went to the U.S
championships
and what is more important for you by
the way to study or let's say your chess
career
what is more important what is more
important your study or your chess
um I I it's like a bit of both right now
um I mean and I'm only like in sophomore
year so uh yeah probably like next year
I have to focus on like APS and stuff
so right yeah like I'm trying to keep it
balanced and trying to let schoolwork
consume me
brilliant congratulations big victory
for you yeah yeah thank you keep up the
good work indeed